mon nom est Jordan Belfort l'année où j'ai
eu 26 ans,
je veux dire 49 millions de dollars, ce qui
m'a vraiment énervé parce que c'était
trois fois moins d'un million par semaine, personne ne
sait si le stock va baisser de
côté ou en cercles pour les gars
vous  les gars savent
okz c'est un faux c'est un tu vois c'est un boisé
dans la poussière de fée était tout cela légal
absolument pas nous gagnions plus d'argent
que nous ne savons quoi en faire ouais mon
argent vous emmène oie VI n'importe quel type d'
alcool que vous pourriez vouloir  le Bureau
nous interdit de le boire bon de me suivre
je suis
mais ce n'est pas possible et ce n'est pas possible
j'aurais été comme ça
comment ça marche réellement c'est un gros
signe d'argent ils sont lancés à la marée
ils collent c'est  leur cadeau d'accord
ils sont construits pour être lancés comme un
arrêt de fléchettes de pelouse merci pour la sécurité la sécurité est d'
abord je vais vouloir avoir une mauvaise
réputation
hmm